my jaw is feeling okay i went to the
[ __ ] dentist
i got this tmj disorder i went to the
dentist and he made me a bite plate
and uh
and he uh he had to fit it [ __ ]
and i i got it in there and he's fitting
it and he's shaving it and he's like all
right let me shave the back and i'll
bite down and it's all even
and it was even and he was like what
hits first and i was like my back molar
my way back molar
and he was like okay well that could be
the reason why your jaw's offsetting and
what we can do is shave your tooth down
and i was like shave my tooth down he
was like
yeah well really there's just two
millimeters of uh of uh enamel on if i
just shave one millimeter off we still
want that other one
bro uh well you know what i mean like
what would it look like i got a guy that
went to school with you
dude you got to do to make my jaw stop
hurting and he came in and he [ __ ] i
said does it hurt and he said it's not
going to hurt me a bit
doctor humor
and i laughed i gave him that laugh
because i was in his world and he was
doing his material and i'm a good
audience dude
even when i'm like this
so he shaved that [ __ ] molar down and
then he said that's interesting and i
said
you never want to hear another man
say well that's interesting when he's
looking down your open throat
one thing you don't want it
one thing you never want to hear when a
guy's
looking down your open throat is
well that's interesting heard it
and i never forgot
so i said what's interesting and he said
you don't
have your back wisdom teeth but you
have your top wisdom teeth you don't
have the bottom wisdom teeth
but you have the top wisdom teeth
in so we flash back
so what do we do then our mind is the
cinema
and we flash back
you call it a memory i call it
my mind is the cinema
and we're flashing back
so i flash back to a time where i'm in
the car going to get my wisdom teeth out
and who's driving my mommy
remember chris you know this is really
tough
oh i'm there again hold on i'm trying to
get back
i'm back flashback my mom yeah and
kristen you know a lot of people get
them all four out at the same time and
it's really traumatic
doc what's interesting you know so what
we're gonna do is we're just gonna get
the bottom ones out because they're a
lot tougher and harder to heal
and then later on in life we got to talk
doc i know what happened
attacker i know what happened
my mommy [ __ ] it up
she made me only get the bottom teeth
out because he said well that's not so
bad because the bottom ones are
more of a [ __ ] i said hey don't ruin it
i want to be mad
i should have got them all at the same
time never hurt anybody in life now that
i think about it
ever get only two [ __ ] wisdom teeth
out
that's ridiculous let's go through all
the pain at once
so he said that could be it let me shave
it down so we shaved it down
and now my jaw closes correctly and i
got the bite plate
and also my jaw feels much better
i could eat a sandwich without thinking
somebody is
blasting a [ __ ] 747 jet
through the side of my temple
we flashback my mind is the cinema
um so you know it's like
i got two [ __ ] wisdom teeth what guy
has two [ __ ] wisdom teeth
i need to get the tibia so you probably
get the top one it's like oh for [ __ ]
sake
all right i'll get the top one i gotta
make a point to get the top and he said
he's like here's the recommendation he
gives me the [ __ ] note with the
recommendation to the doctor
call this guy and i'm like uh just i
gotta keep this
you know and he's like yeah i don't know
where it is i lost it
i'll get out when i get it out dude you
guys know too much about my [ __ ] life
remember when like people like [ __ ]
uh gene hackman were famous and like you
knew
nothing about the inside of his [ __ ]
mouth
now all famous people have instagram
podcasts and [ __ ] tech talk and you
all know that i have two [ __ ] wisdom
[Music]
[Laughter]
teeth
[Music]
oh